hi everyone I'm Chloe Condon senior
developer relations engineer at Google
and today I'm joined by Matt Rin founder
and CEO of clario we're going to be
talking about Claro's partnership with
big query to provide machine learning
tools for their customers Welcome Matt
it's very nice to be here we're so
excited to chat with you today tell us a
little bit about clario for folks that
don't know clario is a um automated
audience Builder it's a specialized type
of a customer data platform is the sort
of Industry jargon for the Tool uh
specializes in taking all of the first
party or owned customer data primarily
from retailers travel hospitality
companies that have large customer
databases bringing that data inhouse and
then um transforming it in in machine
learning parament it's called feature
engineering okay so you're basically
transforming this data into features
which are going to be predictive of some
future behavior for those customers um
most customer data platforms are
oriented towards a single snapshot in
time they take a picture of each of the
customers across maybe a hundred
different characteristics that describe
them um and that is stored always for
what they look like today something
clario does that's very different
because of our orientation towards
machine learning is we create a picture
of every customer every day for multiple
years could you tell us a little bit
about Claro's Ai and machine learning
needs and how you landed with big query
yeah absolutely um I was given the
directive to transform all of the
business from services to software as a
service so a subscription based business
just a small task small just minor yeah
little work um and so when I was given
that task one of the first things I
started looking at is how are we going
to to extract all of this knowledge from
these uh Brilliant Minds that I was
surrounded by uh the co-founders put
that into um software codify that into
the software and then deploy that out to
our customers and so we started an
evaluation of all of the the
technologies that were available at the
time so this is probably 2016 and 17 now
bigquery was really a no-brainer for us
because it was uh very secure the data
is encrypted extremely fast as an
analytic query engine and our primarily
our primary concern was extracting the
fast analytic query we're not a
transactional system it wasn't about
load it was about complicated queries
and being able to extract that data very
quickly um and it was perfect for that
um it was consumption based um the
competitive Solutions I think even to
this day there's a lot of uh
configuration and provision a lot of Dev
Ops that you have to do to set up the
environment uh big query we loaded the
data uh configured the schema a little
bit and it was good to go so that made
it uh very easy for us to implement that
as the back end of the solution um but
you asked specifically about AI ml um at
the time AI was not cool uh so 2017 no
one was talking about AI but ml was big
right everybody understood or not
everybody but many people understood
that there was a significant value to
being able to predict human behavior and
then get in front of that with your
marketing which is how we helped them um
and so uh the machine learning at that
time was a real challenge for us because
um one of the things that you'll hear a
lot about in ml and AI is about
proximity so you load the data from the
customers into bigquery but if the prior
to the launch of bigquery ml if the data
is not located there you have to do that
query and then you have to move that
data somewhere where the analytic
processing the model building can take
place right um and so we looked at a
variety of solutions we were actually
pulling the data out of the system and
using competitive tools and it and it
results in it's not as secure you're
taking the data and moving it somewhere
which is always risky um and uh the time
and overhead and cost associated with
pulling the out and then putting it back
in form of a model basically you've gone
at that point round trip we received the
data from our customers we adopted tools
like DBT which allowed us to uh write
configuration that executed right in
bigquery as well so the raw data from
the customers would be transformed into
the features that would be used um for
the machine learning models the models
would be built right in the platform uh
they would be scored or inferred right
in the platform and then they would be
packaged up and ready to shipped out
wherever the activation against those
customers and and models needed to take
place so how has big query ml
accelerated development how has it
changed the way that you've worked at
clario yeah I think honestly I don't
think what we do at clario would be
possible outside of big query ML and one
of the main reasons is I talked about
feature engineering earlier and that I
idea it's a core concept of machine
learning we've been able to write um
custom transformation code so we write
code that is configured and that code
creates the features um dynamically so
when we configure each client we're able
to go in provide these are the types of
features we want to create and uh those
features are then automatically built in
big query and they are then timelined
for for every customer um so that
Dynamic transformation that configurable
transformation uh is extremely powerful
and the fact that it then feeds directly
into the machine learning models in bql
uh is where the magic lives right that's
where the magic happens um the I think
another part of it is the XG boost the
predictive models that we build for the
customers in bigquery those aren't the
only capabilities of bigquery ml that we
use in the Engineering Process um a lot
of them are about monitoring the
pipeline so bigquery ml has um ARA
forecasting where they're actually able
to look for anomalies and so when
clients are sending us data we're able
to use machine learning to actually
analyze the streams of data that we
receive from customers and look for
anomalous outcomes see where maybe
something broke in the pipeline or maybe
yes right the quality of data coming in
um the acceleration of features I think
is the biggest thing that's been able to
to to occur for the team um we have uh
one of our VP of engineering he says one
of his favorite things is um removing
code from our software uh and what he
means by that is as big query ml has
added additional features and as gcp
overall has added addition addition
features we've actually been able to
delete a significant amount of code um
that supports maintainability right
we're now relying on slas and apis
rather than our own homegrown develop
code um so that has been a huge part of
it we partnered very closely with the
team at Big KL on uh alphas and betas
and now into vertex AI uh related to
their um upcoming features the beauty
there is we got a voice in the pipe or
the um road map for those services and
have actually been able to um influence
that road map in ways that resulted in
offerings that we can embed directly
into the solution and offer right to our
customers so it was not just an
acceleration of the benefit to us as
developers of software but that
acceleration of of capabilities was able
to be transferred right through to our
customers and both of our bottom lines
could you have ever imagined that these
kind of tools would exist today it seems
like these are making a huge difference
in how you think about these things
absolutely um no I could not have ever
imagined this uh this would be the world
um the the latest change is as
mind-blowing right so looking at the
capabilities uh that we've talked about
so far has been mind-blowing uh but then
seeing the capabilities related to geni
uh that are coming online uh in the last
year really sure um has also been
mindblowing and we've been able to be a
early partner with both vertex Ai and uh
big query ml in the geni space um we're
using it uh actively for uh data
cleansing uh it's amazing how you can
talk to a a computer through a natural
language interface like a chatbot right
and you can tell it um I need you to
look through these millions of rows of
data and when you see this pattern in
the data I want you to correct that and
and reshape that data to look like this
um and go and it'll do it within the
database again natively within big query
um those simp they sound very simple to
people like being able to evaluate a
textual string for either sentiment or
for just Quality Cleaning the data um
and it's doing it uh where it actually
is
comprehending uh to the extent that AI
comprehends it's comprehending what it's
seeing in that database and transforming
it with context and and understanding to
some extent of what I need it to look
like on the way out um that is really
gamechanging for data quality um and
we're even looking into the use of gen
through vertex um and the large language
models that Google is working on now to
actually create a um a plain English
interface for development of the queries
and the ml models so I H you asked that
question I'm amazed where it is now I
honestly can't tell you in 24 months
where we'll be right that's what's even
more amazing is thinking about where we
are where we've come from and then where
we're headed is even more mindblowing
well that's all the time we have for
today Matt thank you so much for joining
us and we'll see you all next
time